there have been many such displays in in  response to uh queen elizabeth's death  like that from uju anya a professor of  uh this is what she's a professor of  blackness and multilingualism at  carnegie mellon university and there  carnegie mellon you can spend 60 000 a  year to study utterly useless subjects  while having your brain assaulted and  your soul pummeled by hateful rabid  ideologues like professor ujju who  reacted to the queen's imminent death on  thursday before she had died  with this tweet i heard the chief  monarch of a thieving raping genocide  genocidal empire is finally dying may  her pain be excruciating now the  professor issued more tweets doubling  down on this sentiment she feels  absolutely morally justified in wishing  excruciating pain on a dying elderly  woman  because that dying elderly woman has  committed the crime of being powerful  and also white which is the greatest  crime of all